so we're asked to pick any three pairs
of corresponding input and output values
of the following function and fill the
table accordingly and if necessary round
our answers to the nearest 0.1 and our
function is defined as if I input a tee
what I'm going to output F of T is going
to be negative 2 times my input negative
2 times T plus 3 and so we can just pick
three arbitrary tees and input them into
our function and see what the function
spits out well we could go picking some
really easy T's to compute so for
example if t is equal to 0 then f of T
we could do this in our head but it
would be negative 2 times 0 plus 3 well
negative 2 times 0 is just going to be 0
plus 3 it's just going to be 3 if T is 1
well then f of T is going to be negative
2 times 1 i'll write it in parentheses
plus 3 well negative 2 times 1 is
negative 2 plus 3 is 1 so this is 1 and
just for kicks we could even put a
negative 1 here and once again I could
put in crazier numbers I could have put
in 2.30 seven eight nine but that would
just be more more computation might as
well pick some easy numbers we're just
trying to get a feel for this function
depending on what I input what do I
output and I'm allowed to pick my inputs
so if it's negative one it's going to be
negative 2 so T is now negative one plus
three plus three so negative 2 times
negative 1 is positive 2 plus 3 is 5
it's going to be positive 5 let's do a
few more of these so this says choose
any three points on the following graph
of y is equal to G of X and fill the
table so each column represents a point
if necessary round your answer to the
nearest 0.5 so once again we can see
well there's a bunch of interesting
points here if X is equal to 0 what is G
of X this is y is equal to G of X we see
G of X is equal to negative 1 actually
let me make this a little bit smaller so
that we can see
all on one screen so there we go so now
we should be able to see it a little bit
easier so if x is 0 and once again I'm
just picking 0 because it's easy to see
that when x is 0 Y is equal to negative
1 and y is equal to G of X so g of 0 is
negative 1 see that right from the graph
let's see some other points so we have
this point right over here when X is
negative 1 y which is equal to g of x is
equal to 2 the point 1 comma 2 is on
this line when X is 1 Y is 2 and y is
equal to G of X so G of 1 is 2 all right
let's pick another one here let's see
when X is 1 Y is negative for what X is
sorry this was negative one right over
here when X is negative 1 y is equal to
2 and when X is positive 1 y would be
equal to negative 4 and actually let me
these are the exact same numbers that I
used last time for the inputs let's just
see that you don't have to you know I
could use these numbers but I could pick
different numbers i could say let's see
this number this point over here is
interesting because it looks like both
the x and y coordinates are integers so
if x is negative 3 y is 8 so if x is
negative 3 y is 8 so once again you just
try you should try to pick some values
where you can see where you can clearly
see what the corresponding x and y
coordinates are of that line but any of
those would be valid pairs for a given
input what's G of X going to actually be